اذا حفل تتويج ملوك المملكه المتحده يكون
احتفالا كبيرا وفخما يتم عقده مع تقاليد
تعود الى قرون مضت ففي سن 25 خضعت الملكه
اليزابيث لطقوس خاصه بالدهن باستخدام زيوت
عطريه سيتم عقد حدث مماثل الان للملك
تشارلز الثالث عند موعد تتويجه بحسب بي بي
سي تشمل الطقوس القديمه للدهن استخدام
الزيوت التي يتم حفظها في علبه قديمه
مملوءه بالخلطات العطريه في زجاجه على
الرغم من اخفاء طقوس الدهن عن الجمهور فان
اهميه مسح الملك وجعله يشم رائحه الزيت
العطري هو رمز للامنيات بالنسبه لهم
ليعيشوا حياه طويله وصحيه وسعيده وهذا
ملزم بواجبهم تجاه التاج والبلد وفقا
للمؤرخين الملكيين يعود تاريخ مراسم الدهن
الى القرون القديمه عندما كانت هذه الزيوت
تعتبر رمزا لقوه الملك وذكر المؤرخون
الملكيون حب الملكه اليزابيث للعطور
والزيوت العطريه المستخلصه من حديقتها
باستخدام الزهور والاعشاب النادره التي
تستخدم طبيا وترفيهيا
[موسيقى]